who's excited hey I'm ready to see the
blue jay so Nina and I decided to head
out to downtown disney not called Disney
springs which probably isn't a fantastic
idea because I'm sick and probably need
to see a doctor get some antibiotics but
it's our date night and we haven't had a
lot of time to ourselves and it's kind
of crazy with other kids so we're gonna
head out but before that I gotta show
you this frog oh these guys just chill
chillin frogs we don't get frog just
chillin on the street on the street
since the Toronto so I think that's
pretty cool for those of you native
floridians is probably nothing awesome
to get excited about but Nina sitting
here in the car waiting for me and
waving in playing candy crush we're
gonna go join her and enjoy our time in
Disney springs you ready yeah yes let's
go here we are in downtown disney how
you feeling
Oh God like sick I feel like I need
something sweet like a sweet drink or
something okay we're gonna have fun
yeah this is my boy
so because I took over TDs and I have a
physical retail store I've been super
curious about interiors and ceilings and
layouts and as soon as I walk into this
building you merely notice
right
how cool it is Nina
just jump and trying to get in anyway i
don't know i'm not going to do anything
like this but it's funky it's cool i
like I look like what
look just like it check it it what's it
chip in there the starbucks and for st.
Patrick's Day they have a special
shamrock Frappuccino pot of gold
carthagena luck of the Irish I think I
gotta get the shamrock cappuccino milky
chocolate green blended beverage Oh Nina
we got to get one when you're sick
you're supposed to have a cold
frappuccinos what's
name is shaking her head yeah see you're
going up and down she said yeah this is
it venti luck of the Irish oh it's weird
it's like
no this is not their best a little
disappointed in starbucks on this one
but I applaud the effort and it sucked
me into when you try it it's like matcha
March are with mint with chocolate Nevel
ended kinetic imitated please can I
basically oh please sir please okay
alright it's a 11 o'clock
as I car stuff is coming up
which is not good I'm probably a sign
that we shouldn't be out so we're going
to go home and sleep and then start
today tomorrow heading off to the
baseball game
right
all right we'll check it tomorrow bye
bye hey what day is it they say 6 a-7
know they 6 i'm not feeling that great
so Louise gonna drive to dunedin so the
kids are in the car where we going yeah
I don't know if I'm gonna sleep we'll
see what happens where get some
breakfast get a coffee on the road maybe
sleep when we get there on the way there
and enjoy all right here we go maybe
some shut-eye and then go jays go all
right we made it that's the first time
in three years about you been on time
hello ration though feeling the pain
headache throat I got a coffee on the
way and not prevented my napping yeah
we're here we're early we're early for
the first time I said it's gonna take an
hour and a half and that you took an
hour and a half what do you think Nina
yeah I know in the last two years we've
been we got free beer tickets with our
parking too not that we're going to
drink beer but it's an interesting
marketing promotion so we're gonna go
get our seats I'm sure on the chase it
was excited I'm ready to see the blue
jay here we go
you really get ice cream in the middle
of it we're going to do it today okay
you see if you're a good boy
Joe what's your just when you have 230
we're coming were coming silly can't say
they cut you too hot donkey show me why
okay relax eat one first and then see if
you're good about you not hungry
it's gonna get a piezo left the other
number 21 to get up here Michael
Saunders like a real beer yes
me out to the ballgame take me out to
the crowd buy me some peanuts and
cracker jack I don't care if I never get
back and will root for the Blue Jays
don't win it's a shame for it's one two
three strikes you're out at the old ball
game
blue jays win guess I'm miss are gonna
win the World Series
Louise got something to say God Daniel
Blue Jays waived your fans sold out sold
out crowd at spring training camp you
can't even wave it's not delightful not
alike rush the latest I've ever been
fair play related oh you left too late
your left wing you're here just way too
late I know today if we're the flight
back no really no no it's like an hour
every hour and then hole oh I forgot
same stuff yeah where it's my laptop
come back and any way back here either I
didn't do a single film because it's
been non-stop non-stop brush everything
is here how you doing the kids are there
you know anything about Louis somewhere
in the back so I ready we've arrived in
toronto how you doing
you know throat estar my throat sore
tired hungry a little bit grumpy did you
hurt yourself mar you faked hurting if i
gave you a ticket what what happened
really so Nina we're gonna do this again
I don't know how to genetic too soon to
tell maybe because of the pressure up
today it's crazy okay so they never
loaded our bag so hopefully arrives
tonight the chaos continues to the day
all right that's it bye everyone thanks
for joining us on our trip